god i [ __ ] with tiger i was telling
chappelle this so he's
i came home yesterday from the airport
he's like dad you want me to make you a
bracelet i made mom and grandma abrasive
i'm like yeah dude make
do it up and then he makes it it's all
pink and white come on dude you're
making
uh girly [ __ ] man i go mix it up there
can we get a little the red little the
black
he's like oh okay okay and then i leave
i would go to the bathroom
i guess his mom was like i thought you
made uh dad a bracelet already goes
i did mom but i'm making girly [ __ ]
she's
what's wrong with pink though uh it was
just like yellow pink like i can't
you know it was very pastel yeah it's
very easter
yeah yes speaking of girlies
so uh a-rod has come out with his own
line of makeup and the internet's kind
of split on this
yeah because some people are like oh
yeah cool guys wearing makeup who cares
and
other people were like why the [ __ ] is
that rod making makeup like why does he
have a makeup line he's been tv so long
he decided to launch his own makeup line
i guess i think he's sealer though a
concealer what's concealer
concealer is basically uh like a more
pigmented foundation to cover up your
dark spots
to make everything just even so if you
can't cover up this dark spot
there is makeup for you now it's like
pimples and stuff like that
we can find a savage x fenty i just
don't get why
guys i think it's because jlo recently
released her skincare and they probably
started it together when they were still
i thought they weren't together though
they're not anymore
peter gabriel oh you know
yes i can see
the city lights yes every white person
okay
every white person came in closer
peter gabriel you know like he's my
generation literally
how about we met him how about we met
his exact doppelganger
that runs his improv she's like this
black girl same color sim
same everything piercing blue eyes
coming to the green where the mask on
she goes
what's up dudes all right man we're
gonna have fun show tonight hope you
guys catch a vibe
i'll see you out there all right and
then uh i think it goes i'll come up the
nipsy hustle she's like not
you sure familiar want to come out some
rancid or something we're like no we're
good
she was just like him just like me wow
just just as dark as she comes
she comes in when he goes on stage comes
he goes hey do you have a charger by any
chance
the controller for my video game is
running low bro i could use you can
charge you to play some video games i'm
like no i don't
know no problem dude no problem dude
but she was like dark as him like you
would not expect
it give it up for your first comic
justin elliott
this crowd is rocking tonight wow
it was the piercing blue eyes yeah or
were they green
yeah she was tiny yeah it was funny so
funny i was like
she walked out i was like is that me you
know that spider-man meme where they're
both playing at each other i was like
chappelle is that your sister all right
everybody we have a rocking show tonight
see you guys out there we're gonna make
it a reality babe
that's great she was the best she was so
great yeah she was great
okay wait wait let's go back to
concealer yeah
my over under is that going to sell i
don't know
i don't think anybody's buying it
anybody's buying stevie does
yeah every now and then if he has like a
little like oh like a zit or something
cover it up i guess oh that's what it
does yeah oh
okay i was thinking it was like full on
like no you don't you can spot use it
it's spot yeah
if i'm on tv you can use it for like
under your dark eyes
oh okay yeah yeah i guess that's wait
can you use it i got it for pimples yeah
yeah i'll do like a little dab of [ __ ]
all right what a little dab
do you yeah a little bit don't say that
in elementary school
um yeah okay well i don't know about
full makeup though
mascara bro yeah yeah pimples i'll cover
pimples yeah
you know how you give out a bad breakout
i don't know what i do though when i do
i'll have my girl do it though i don't
know yeah
[ __ ] line yeah that's the thing i'm
like okay i'll go on camera today
you're gonna go buy concealer as a man i
don't know
i like i don't see that making lots of
money they said there's many times
people be surprised how many guys use it
for like blemishes and yeah
like if i had that [ __ ] in high school
when i might had [ __ ] pizza face
sign me up yeah yeah it would have
really helped me out i just think dudes
are
lazy but i mean yeah would you say guys
are lazy though with that [ __ ]
yeah you'd be surprised yeah how many
guys are in the fashion like the sneaker
heads yeah
for sure the sneaker has a wear makeup
that's what's different about it i'm
just saying guys are into fashion oh
yeah a lot of guys are in fashion
younger kids are really into like
painting their nails and doing their
makeup guys
yeah like the androgynous kind of like
bts look isn't it i've seen that a lot
mm-hmm but like you the one that you're
breaking like you always dressed pretty
well
no sir you read the room wrong i read
the room wrong
he is the furthest thing from but i'm
just i just he's older
i think i i know he's like i'm bombed on
that sentence i just don't know how to
you know like i if it fits it's worth
the same this uniform for seven years
he's like batman i do it was the same
colored shirts and blazers and
he's like a cartoon if you if you dress
up you just put a blazer over that
that's what you do i bought expensive
blazers yeah and caught like
i've spent money and they're on my
hanger and the dust has settled
into i think if you work college sure
did just make you look older i just
became really colored surely
every time i started doing that and
rogan would be like well you look like a
[ __ ] librarian or a teacher you get a
salesman yeah
you're like a history teacher when you
dress up yeah yeah oh you're like
but you don't look bad i'm trying to
look at what i'm saying i look like a
[ __ ]
like i teach uh social studies you're
italian in
irish irish yeah